hbo's preview for episode 3 has dropped
with a great sneak peek just how far in
time we're going and what we can expect
warning this is a full book and trailer
spoiler video so if you're wanting
something more non-spoilery check out my
weekly episode breakdowns which i'll
leave a link to in the description below
as well as for the hbo trailer now let's
get into it a pretty empty small council
with the dejected king viserys watching
his daughter rhaenyra saunter off if
there's one big theme this preview has
it's how rhaenyra deals with the
shocking news that her dad will wed her
best friend allison hightower it'll be
interesting if they actually show us
this wedding or if we simply fast
forward about one and a half to two
years from the events of episode two
this is my rough estimate considering
we'll see allison and viserys's first
child aegon ii named of course after the
first targaryen king aegon the conqueror
the same aegon who had the dream about a
great evil sweeping the land during a
long winter rhaenyra is wearing a really
interesting dress here is it one of her
normal ones or is it for some special
event the king himself also carries with
him the cat's paw dagger which he held
suspiciously close when he told renera
about aegon's dream otto tells his
daughter that aegon will be king this
would go against what viserys told
renera in episode 2 that she would
remain his heir i'm wondering if we're
at driftmark here the home of the
valerians this certainly doesn't look
like the red keep and there are these
sea snake type sculptures on the walls
and cups bonus points if you caught the
little doll here likely for aegon you'll
also notice alcent here with their hair
in this type of braid the same braid
will see her in while the king shows off
aegon to the crowd so i think we'll see
the king and queen going around the
realm to show the child off proving that
everything is well and good we aren't
exactly sure where this takes place
there's almost no descript banners
however take a look at two of the
prominent men watching aegon paraded
about one we've met the king's master of
laws lord lionel strong so i don't think
it's that far of a stretch to think that
the man beside him with a cane is one of
his sons sir loris strong he was after
all nicknamed lara's clubfoot because
his feet were twisted at birth the
historians who wrote the accounts found
in fire and blood find lloris to be one
of the most baffling characters whose
allegiances are never fully known this
makes him an especially dangerous
character i like this shot here of young
aegon being passed to his father where
you can make out he's been playing with
a little toy dragon from what i've read
aegon ii will be portrayed by three
different actors one as an infant a
child and an adult aegon will ride
sunfire who we haven't seen in the show
yet but whom we've seen in the previews
rhaenyra here looking a bit dejected in
what appears to be the small council
chamber you can make out some white hair
and possibly a dagger hilt so i'm
wondering if this is part of the first
shot we saw earlier whatever it is it
does not look like good news for
rhaenyra the king feeds his son in the
royal carriage while telling renera she
will soon be with her own son rhaenyra
will have her first child with coreless
valerian's son lenore roughly seven
years after the birth of aegon ii we've
seen the two together in the previews
however it looks like in this episode
the writers are setting up rhaenyra's
romance with sir kristen cole rhaenyra
will tell her father that she does not
wish to marry but she like him is bound
to duty i wonder if this scene is where
he tells her that she is to wed lenore
remember we did see otto and alison at
driftmark the home of the valerians so
it's possible all of this is connected
bonus points if you caught the little
cup for our cupbearer beside her in the
carriage alison tells what is likely
rhaenyra that things don't have to be
this way hinting that their friendship
is on the rocks this looks to take place
at the weirwood tree at the red keep
which is ironic since that's where we
saw their friendship at its strongest
rhaenyra tells her that no one is here
for her as we catch a glimpse of sir
kristen cole watching her ride off sir
kristen is tasked with rhaenyra's
protection so obviously he goes after
her we've seen a better shot of this in
the season trailer unfortunately for
rhaenyra she's stalked by a wild animal
a boar by the looks of it a boar is also
what mortally wounded robert baratheon
there also appears to be some armor here
on the bottom left sir kristen will
remove a sword from it but it's unclear
whether this person or armor was dead
slash here beforehand we've seen in the
trailer that kristen and rhaenyra spend
the night by campfire where rhaenyra
asked him do you think the realm will
ever accept me as that queen the
relationship between rhaenyra and sir
kristen is extremely interesting because
the book offers multiple scenarios on
how their love turns to poison in one
sir kristen rejects renera on account of
his kingsguard oath that he is never to
wed or have a partner and in the other
it's renera who will end up rejecting
sir kristen with septon ustus stating
that a targaryen was meant to be more
than a wife of a cell sword so i'm super
interested which direction the writers
will take this corliss warns that crab
feeder cragus rahar has dug his heels in
on bloodstone the largest of the islands
in the stepstones we also get our first
shot of corliss in this badass armor
this appears to be bloodstone under
siege giant balls of flame from siege
equipment on the island suggest the
ships here are corlisses to the left we
can make out a dragon this could either
be daemon's karaxis or lanor's sea smoke
the king here prepares to jab a bloody
spear i wonder if he'll be killing that
boar that attacked rhaenyra or perhaps
this is something else entirely corliss
and his men along with daemon use these
pieces to plan out their attack behind
daemon you can make out corliss's son
lenore who we last saw in episode 1 as a
child what ensues is a giant battle
between the valerian daemon alliance and
craga strahar backed by the triarchy
corliss exclaims that they're losing and
we even see damon shot with an arrow it
seems like one of those all is lost
moments until a dragon comes in to turn
the tides i actually think this is sea
smoke who is ridden by lenore this
doesn't look like caraxas to me and we
saw daemon injured by an arrow but it
also makes me question why damon didn't
just ride in with his dragon in the
first place perhaps he wants to prove
himself in battle without the help of
one that way no one can ever claim the
only reason he's as powerful as he is is
because of his dragon corliss did say to
him last episode that the stepstones
would be the perfect opportunity for him
to prove himself another question i have
is whether in this episode we'll see the
end of kragestrahar the war of the
stepstones was a two-year series of
battles in the book daemon ends up
beheading kragus with his sword dark
sister what i want to know is how long
these stepstones arc will go in the
series one of the trailers actually
shows prince damon returning to king's
landing holding what appears to be a
hammer could this be the same hammer
craga strahar used to nail his victims
corliss crowned damon the king of the
stepstones and narrow sea after his
victories there but the book has daemon
giving up that crown to viserys bending
the knee and the two reconcile with
damon getting a seat back on the small
council so that's it for the episode 3
preview i can't wait until next week
when i'm proven completely wrong be sure
to like and subscribe and if you haven't
seen my episode 2 breakdown be sure to
check that out you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember it's a crispin
wasn't it
you